[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de TV
78 nous sommes le jeudi 16 décembre
voici les titres
en cette fin d'année c'est l'une des
professions les plus touchées par la
crise sanitaire les traiteurs font face
à de nombreuses annulations de
prestations réception pour notre prise
ou d'associations dans une période
charnière pour leur commerce Jean-Marc
zenoud dirigeant Davos service traiteur
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et notre invité
sur votre table pour les fêtes
d’ailleurs pourquoi ne pas choisir un
dessert yvelinois de nombreuses recettes
sont par exemple possibles pour la
traditionnelle bûche de Noël exemple
adversailles où nous avons pu goûter les
préparations de deux chocolatiers à la
Reine Astrid et la pâtisserie fine enfin
la suite de nos rétrospectives de
l'année 2021 ce soir retour sur les
événements marquants qui se sont
déroulés entre juillet et septembre
dernier
la scène à choqué à Mantes-la-Jolie un
homme tirant en l'air en pleine rue et
braquant plusieurs véhicules avant de
mettre fin à ses jours des faits qui se
sont produits mardi au pied de la tour
Vega dont le quartier du Val Fourré et
de jour après le drame la mairie de
Mantes-la-Jolie a mis en place une
cellule d'écoute psychologiques elle est
installée depuis aujourd'hui au centre
médico-social Frédéric Chopin et est
assuré par le SAMU et la Croix-Rouge
elle sera encore accessible demain
vendredi de 10 heures à 14h vous pouvez
vous y rendre sans rendez-vous
dans l'actualité également ce canular
téléphonique qui a mobilisé les forces
de l'ordre plusieurs patrouilles mais
aussi un détachement du raid et des CRS
sont intervenus ce mercredi soir au
centre commercial Vélizy 2 la raison un
appel téléphonique passer à partir de
18h45 et signalant une prise d'otages
par un ou plusieurs individus dans le
quartier dans le cinéma UGC c'était dans
le cinéma UGC levée de doute finalement
à 20h auparavant par précaution le
cinéma et les restaurants ont été
évacués aucune prise d'otages mais les
fouilles ont abouti sur l'interpellation
de trois personnes deux hommes ayant un
couteau dans leur poche et un troisième
homme qui avait sur lui une vingtaine de
couteaux à lames rétractile à cran
d'arrêt à l'individu se dit
collectionneur quant à l'appel
téléphonique il aurait été effectué par
une femme depuis un poste fixe
directement depuis le centre commercial
d'après une source cité par nos
confrères de 78 actu pour leur l'auteur
des faits n'a pas été identifié
[Musique]
les fêtes approchent à grands pas demain
soir vendredi les élèves seront déjà en
vacances pour deux semaines la fin
d'année c'est une période charnière pour
de nombreux professionnels de nombreux
secteurs comme celui des traiteurs et on
en parle avec mon invité Jean-Marc the
noue qui est avec moi bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le dirigeant de l'entreprise à
votre service traiteur c'est un traiteur
familial spécialisé dans le service aux
entreprises mais vous travaillez aussi
avec des particuliers sur des événements
comme les mariages et vous êtes
installés à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux début décembre le
gouvernement avait appelé à limiter les
moments de convivialité en entreprise
est-ce que vous avez eu à déplorer
depuis cette annonce de nombreuses
annulations il ne s'est pas passé une
journée sans qu'on ait une dizaine de
coups de téléphone pour des annulations
de prestations d'entreprises
d'associations on en est pas encore aux
particuliers mais
oui je suis la période charnière c'est
milieu de la semaine dernière et toute
cette semaine ou toutes les entreprises
avant les vacances scolaires font leurs
événements
pour fêter la fin de l'année tout a été
annulé pour ainsi dire j'ai perdu plus
de 800 couverts là sur les 8 derniers
jours
c'est simple l'annonce a dû être faite
le 2 puisque à partir du 3 le téléphone
a continuellement sonner pour nous dire
voilà bah on annule le signe on annule
ça et toutes les devis qui étaient en
cours finalement ne se sont pas
concrétisés donc c'est encore plus de
couvert qu'on aurait pu perdre qu'on a
perdu mais qui eux n'étaient pas définis
les 812 je parle était déjà signé des
fin novembre des fin novembre
qui aurait pu aboutir s'il n'avait pas
eu ces annonces on parle de de quel type
d'événements aussi bien des repas
d'entreprise ça peut être aussi des vœux
de mairies vous me disiez alors oui tout
à fait donc là je parle des 800 c'est
seulement les 8 derniers jours mais
janvier les vœux fait dans les
entreprises mais surtout ceux des
mairies ont été annulés il y a
maintenant c'est officiel depuis quatre
cinq jours suite la à la prestation du
Premier ministre Castex qui a annoncé
que les vœux auraient lieu mais pas la
petite cérémonie qui est derrière de
galette de de peau cocktail ou autre et
donc nous ça représente plus de 1600 à
1800 couverts d'années déjà aujourd'hui
et alors qu'ils étaient signés pour un
manque à gagner à là moi je perds sur
deux mois 520 150 000 euros sur sur
cette période là qui est charnière vous
le disiez nous c'est pas important
de notre chiffre d'affaires fait en deux
mois sur l'année
est-ce que vous aviez déjà acheté des
marchandises pour cette période on a
essayé de limiter les choses parce que
c'est l'annonce a quand même été assez
rapide elle a été faite tout début
décembre donc on savait de toute façon
que ça serait un petit peu difficile
donc on a retenu mais il y avait des
foie gras à faire donc il a fallu
commencer à lancer bah ils sont prêts
pour pour Noël quoi c'est il y a juste
une semaine de décalage mais non on a
quand même limité les pertes là nous on
a on avait prévu un petit peu la chose
ce qu'on a perdu c'est c'est tout le
personnel qui était prévu donc
intérimaire extra etc pour cette période
non j'avais trois contrats à faire pour
un mois qui était prévu
là j'ai alignés tout de suite et puis
pour toutes les prestations de janvier
ou il nous fallait beaucoup de personnel
c'est 50 à 60 vacations qui ont été
annulés qui étaient déjà réservés j'ai
appelé mes chefs d'équipe
je les avais réservés et puis bah la
dernièrement c'est moi qui ai commencé à
appeler pour annuler moi aussi
prestations les quelques prestations que
vous pouvez encore honorer elle pèse sur
quelques personnes au sein de
l'entreprise c'est simplement sur le
personnel fixe que on a embauché dès le
début septembre puisque on a vraiment
redémarré au dernier trimestre après une
année un peu un peu chaotique
adapté en proposant des commandes
peut-être sur des volumes moins grands
pour de petites commandes 3-4 personnes
c'est ça tout à fait oui
on s'est mis à la vente à emporter des
petites commandes de 2 3 voire même une
personne chose que l'on ne faisait
jamais puisqu'on faisait surtout des
réceptions pour 40 50 60 personnes les
entreprises quand ils nous appellent
c'est minimum 20 personne donc là on
s'est mis à faire oui de la dînette pour
pour nous parce que travailler pour deux
trois personnes c'est pas les habitudes
on a des rondos on travaille avec du
matériel
énorme quoi une poêle chez moi elle fait
20 litres voilà donc non on a dû
s'adapter donc on s'est bien débrouillé
pendant toute l'année puisque tout le
personnel était au chômage donc on est
resté seul avec ma femme pour maintenir
l'activité de la société et on a
découvert nos voisins en fait les les
clients tout autour qui avaient besoin
de sortir qui était seul avec leur femme
pour un anniversaire de mariage il y a
pas moyen de d'aller au restaurant et
ben on a fait des repas de
d'anniversaire de mariage pour pour nos
clients c'est comme ça qu'on a commencé
et puis on a fait après boule de neige
adaptez-vous d'activité normale depuis
septembre dès le premier septembre notre
clientèle entreprise et reparti de plus
belle donc plateau repas réunion buffet
cocktail
ça a été comme ça sur septembre
novembre octobre on a aussi bien bien
travaillé et là on avait un mois de
décembre vraiment bien rempli et bah ça
s'est arrêté et puis les annulations ont
commencé et l'activité oui on fait
beaucoup de ménage dans les labos c'est
l'activité principale en ce moment une
dernière question est-ce que vous êtes
du coup dans quel état d'esprit parce
que on rappelle que demain de vendredi
de nouvelles annonces du gouvernement le
gouvernement qui a déjà dit que le
secteur de l'événementiel serait aidé
dans cette période est-ce que vous
attendez de nouvelles annonces est-ce
que vous voulez les craignez aussi
justement alors j'ai énormément peur
pour Noël et Nouvel An puisque les
annonces concernent les fêtes donc les
particuliers et on s'était retranché un
petit peu sur nos commandes pour la
soirée du réveillon la soirée de Noël le
midi de Noël et la le réveillon de la
Saint-Sylvestre et j'ai bien peur
puisque on a beaucoup de clients qui ont
commandé pour 15 16 personne si on nous
refait le coût de l'année dernière à
dire pas plus de 6 personnes à table et
bah ça va nous faire encore un grand
manque à gagner c'est la moitié de ce
qui est réservé c'est-à-dire
s'en est à 150 couverts le 24 on est à
60 le 25 le Nouvel An ça commence déjà à
tomber puisqu'on avait aussi des grosses
des grosses associations qui se
réunissaient qui prenaient une salle et
qui nous faisait un buffet ou un
cocktail la d'office les mairies ont qui
possèdent des des salles on dit que
c'était pas possible il y aurait pas de
cocktail il y aurait pas de buffet dans
dans leur salle donc là on a déjà perdu
forcément les plus bonnes non non c'est
pas les deux mois qui arrivent là sont
pas les
très belles à voir
merci Jean-Marc zenoud d'être venu
témoigner cette période en plateau
période forcément difficile pour le
secteur entier des traiteurs je rappelle
que vous êtes vous le dirigeant dans
votre service traiteur une entreprise
spécialisée donc dans les traiteurs qui
est installé à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
concernant les annonces dont on parlait
sur cette crise sanitaire le
gouvernement doit en faire de nouvelles
demain vendredi à la suite et d'un
nouveau conseil sanitaire et ce à une
semaine de se réveiller de Noël sur
votre table justement pour les fêtes
elle conclut très souvent votre repas
c'est la bûche de Noël glacée rouler
faite maison de très nombreuses recettes
sont possibles deux gourmands de la
rédaction Mélanie poquet et Bixente et
incendie sont allés dans les coulisses
de chocolatiers à la Reine Astrid et la
pâtisserie fine qui ont tous deux des
boutiques à Versailles se sont-ils
laissés séduire regarder
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui avec Mélanie
nous ne sommes pas collègue nous sommes
adversaires deux équipes qui vont
s'affronter pour le combat du meilleur
dessert de Noël et oui Bixente je sais
pas si vous savez mais entre 8 et 10
millions de bus ont commandés chaque
année ce qui pousse les pâtissiers à
rivaliser toujours plus d'imagination
pour trouver de nouvelles recettes
encore plus gourmandes Mélanie vous
serez donc dans l'équipe de la Reine
Astrid et moi-même celle de la
pâtisserie fine à Versailles et puis pas
plus de mots partons tout de suite à
Meudon c'est là où se trouve le
laboratoire de Christophe Bertrand
[Musique]
Christophe Bertrand bonjour alors cette
année dans vos préparations vous avez
choisi le mucilage de cacao est-ce que
on peut tout de suite lever le voile de
ce mucilage oui c'est quelque chose que
les consommateurs ne connaissent pas et
qui va être assez surprenant parce que
ils vont donc manger une bûche dont la
totalité est issue de la cabosse tout
vient de la cabosse et à l'intérieur du
fruit il y a une petite pulpe blanche
qui entoure les fèves de cacao cette
petite pile peu blanche va servir elle
est super sucrée ça ressemble à du kiwi
l'aloe vera du litchi la façon un peu la
banane on mange du fruit alors on mange
du fruit oui justement donc ça veut dire
que sachant que c'est un fruit et comme
il faut manger cinq fruits et légumes
tous les jours lorsque vous mangez du
chocolat puis ça c'est moi qui l'ai
décidé et bien ça rentre dans les fruits
et légumes qu'il faut manger tous les
jours ça va donner l'eau à la bouche
votre chef pâtissier Mathieu zupetti va
nous révéler la recette moi je vais
aller du côté du labo et il va falloir
que je résiste je pense
Mathieu bonjour Mélanie c'est vous qui
allez nous révéler les secrets de cette
bûche première étape j'imagine
aujourd'hui on est sur un mucilage donc
on va faire notre insert mucilage on
prend notre mutuelle on va le faire
chauffer on va le monter un petit peu en
température je vais garnir ma poche je
sais pas vous mais moi j'ai du mal à
résister en fait notre moule une petite
couche de crème donc voilà là on a le
crémeux qui va apporter un petit peu
d'amertume je viens fermer délicatement
ma petite mousse
donc j'ai fait une nougatine grouille
cacao une petite pointe de chocolat
quelques cacao on savait pas mais il y
en a vraiment de toutes les couleurs et
à divers des jaunes des roses enfin des
rouges et voilà maintenant on peut
savoir on peut savourer c'est le moment
d'exister merci Mathieu les bûches sont
déjà disponibles dans les boutiques de
la Reine Astrid Bixente à vous de
relever le défi parce que là il y a du
niveau
Mélanie vous m'avez demandé du niveau je
vous ai pris au mot il est passé par
Alain Ducasse la maison Dalloyau et
l'hôtellerie à Paris mesdames et
messieurs Sébastien cerveau bonjour
bonjour donc pourquoi vous êtes vous
lancez dans ce défi d'ouvrir votre
propre institut bah ça a toujours été un
rêve en fait d'ouvrir une pâtisserie
avec avec ma femme et c'est vrai que
j'ai traversé un petit peu le monde
pendant une dizaine d'années avec mon
métier de consultant international et
voilà il était temps de s'installer et à
Versailles c'est vrai que ça nous
correspondait bien sur le côté chic et
Yogam de la ville au menu justement 5
bus l'exotique l'Impérial la Saint Louis
et une petite spécificité une bûche
finesse donc avec un moule un peu
spécifique un peu en forme de torsade
cette année ces pommes spéculoos donc
des parfums un peu régressifs et que
tout le monde apprécie en règle générale
et bien je vous propose d'ailleurs
d'aller voir
l'étape l'élaboration de cette bûche
tout de suite ben là j'ai fait en fait
et je vais le verser sur mes pommes pour
faire infuser en fait mes pommes alors
ici on a notre moule à bûche donc c'est
l'insert donc ça ça doit être taillé
vraiment à la perfection pour voilà il
faut très bien exactement ensuite je
vais pocher donc mon crémeuse spéculoos
ensuite je vais prendre mes pommes
délicatement je vais les poser dans mon
moule ensuite je vais refermer donc la
bûche avec l'autre partie de biscuit
donc là je réalise la mousse vanille de
Tahiti donc là on est une heure plus
tard l'insert a été sorti du grand froid
et on va pouvoir commencer vraiment
l'assemblage donc là je vais masquer le
moule remonter la mousse sur les les
extrémités et ensuite je vais rabattre
un petit peu la mousse et mettre le
croustillant je vais la passer
maintenant au grand froid voilà Mélanie
notre bûche est maintenant terminée du
côté du niveau je pense que ça va être
difficile de nous départager et vous
qu'est-ce que vous choisissez
[Musique]
beaucoup de niveaux effectivement et
après la bûche peut-être vous
restera-t-il encore une place pour une
part de galette dans la suite de Noël et
du réveillon et de la Saint-Sylvestre
l'épiphanie a aussi son produit fort
chaque année à la Chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat Île-de-France Yveline
organise la compétition pour élire la
meilleure galette aux amandes du
département le palmarès a été dévoilé
cette semaine une huitième édition
remportée par une boulangerie de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye regardez ce sujet
de notre très gros moment encore Bixente
mais rien sansisteban
[Musique]
c'est ici à la boulangerie du château de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye que se trouve la
meilleure galette aux amandes des
Yvelines édition 2022 elle est préparée
de bon matin par Sébastien Briet
j'ai fait quatre galettes et il fallait
les quatre galettes soient vraiment
l'identique on a vu j'ai vu d'autres
galettes et je pense que c'est vraiment
la régularité j'avais une galette qui
était vraiment très très assez élevé
mais en même temps très plate et pas
bombé la galette qui fait 30 cm c'est la
taille requis pour le concours toute
façon un premier prix décerné pour une
galette travaillait avec précision
il faut surtout pas trop trancher le
feuilletage après à la cuisson avec le
développement du feuilletage et ben on
voit apparaître le le décor et même des
gens qui demandent des galettes des
parfums qu'on n'a pas forcément mais
c'est pas un problème parce que là-bas
c'est toujours un peu près la même une
crème d'amandes un feuilletage ce qui
compte c'est la régularité un maximum de
régularité parce que si tu en as un qui
est gros qui est petit après c'est parti
pour à peu près une heure de cuisson à
170 degrés ça va nous permettre aussi de
nous faire découvrir un petit peu plus
et puis vendre sur mon beaucoup de
galettes
Sébastien a d'ailleurs remporté le
deuxième prix du meilleur salarié de
récompense symbolique pour le gérant
Michael forcher ça prouve que on est
dans le vrai on est on est vraiment dans
le 100% fait maison c'était très
important pour moi les gens sont
sensibles je pense aujourd'hui
à ce genre de concours aujourd'hui on
s'approprie un peu le boulanger on va
chez mon boulanger et c'est une fierté
pour moi et pour tous mes clients la
boulangerie est qualifiée pour le
concours régional qu'elle connaît déjà
puisque son croissant avait terminé
deuxième ville de France de galettes
seront envoyés pour être jugés entre le
4 et le 7 janvier
pendant 15 jours la Commanderie à
Élancourt a fait patienter petit et
grands avec son Noël décalé entre
patinoire exposition et atelier retour
avec Mélanie poquet
[Musique]
aladdin et Jasmine ne sont pas du voyage
mais avec son manège du Contrevent la
compagnie grande et Douglas proposait
une pause aérienne et poétique
un décor avec pas mal de livres et de
qui invite au voyageur c'est
qu'improvisé pour pour des questions
aussi techniques c'est que j'ai besoin
je sais jamais quand le manège va
vraiment s'arrêter donc je pourrais pas
faire un autre morceau déjà écrit et
puis c'est beaucoup plus plaisant pour
moi
d'improviser en fonction de ce qu'il y a
c'était très agréable
vraiment tout doux avec la musique
bonne expérience c'était sympa la
Commanderie a multipliée atelier
rendez-vous pour son temps fort de cette
quinzaine décalée pour cette nouvelle
édition le marché des associations
solidaires et créateurs locaux étaient à
nouveau proposé 650 personnes ce sont
les CC séduire le samedi 11 décembre les
créneaux de patinoires sont complets les
ateliers sont complets les artisans et
créateurs sont contents de l'affluence
proposée des ateliers qui sont un petit
peu décalés qui sont pas forcément
l'atelier traditionnel qu'on pourrait
attendre pour Noël pour préparer Noël
mais qui nous servent aussi à préparer
Noël le Noël décalé a pris fin ce
mercredi 15 décembre la magie de l'avant
continue patience plus que quelques
jours avant le réveillon
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité yvelinois
cette visite ministérielle ce jeudi dans
le département Roselyne Bachelot était à
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines en fin
d'après-midi la ministre de la Culture a
visité un lieu phare du sud-yvelines la
maison Triolet Aragon c'est dans ce
moulin datant de la fin du 12e siècle
que vécu le couple d'écrivain Elsa
Triolet Louis Aragon ils écrivir
quelques-unes de leur plus belle œuvres
leur tombeau est d'ailleurs situé dans
le parc de cinq hectares la suite de nos
rétrospectives de 2021 toute cette
semaine la rédaction de TV 78 revient
sur les faits marquants de cette année
ce soir ce sont les mois de juillet à
septembre que nous avons dans le
rétroviseur au volant Michael el midro
l’étévelinois 2021 était sportif avec
les Jeux Olympiques de Tokyo 11 athlètes
cet événement planétaire mention
spéciale 3 tripathlètes de Poissy qui
remporte la médaille de bronze tout
comme Christopher six en équitation le
versailly Valentin portant handball et
Guillaume chaîne de Sartrouville
remporte la médaille d'or les Jeux de
Tokyo à peine refermer tous les regards
sont désormais tournés vers les JO de
2024 à Paris le vélodrome de 50 ans
Yvelines accueilli en septembre le
passage des drapeaux olympiques dans sa
structure du cyclisme également dans les
Yvelines avec le Tour de France la
dernière étape est partie depuis château
pogacchard vainqueur de cette édition
2021 et Julian Alaphilippe était présent
sur la ligne de départ
côté politique le Conseil d'État a
tranché il faudra revoter pour les
élections municipales à Trappes le maire
élu en 2020 à l'iraba était sanctionné
suite à les infractions pendant sa
campagne les dates des nouvelles
élections les 10 et 17 octobre de son
côté Valérie Pécresse a annoncé sa
candidature pour les élections
présidentielles de 2022 l'ancienne
député des Yvelines venaient d'être
réélu pour un second mandat à la tête de
la région Île-de-France depuis le 21
janvier est obligatoire de présenter un
pass sanitaire pour accéder au lieu de
loisirs et de culture comme les musées
où les cinémas les salles obscures ont
enregistré une chute de la fréquentation
de
70%, le Pass sanitaire devient également
obligatoire à partir du 9 août pour
aller manger au restaurant à Trappes
première étape pour le chantier de
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 le
pont Marcel Cachin était démoli dans la
nuit du 17 au 18 août il surplombait la
N10 au niveau de la mairie le chantier
d'envergure devrait durer 6 ans
en septembre le musée départemental
Maurice Denis installé à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye Rouvres ses
portables et 3 ans de travaux le jardin
et le bâtiment ont été restauré une
exposition inaugurale dédiée à l'artiste
peintre a été réalisé le week-end des 11
et 12 septembre le château de Versailles
accueillait la plus grande
reconstitution historique d'époque 400
passionnés en fait revivre Napoléon en
se bicentenaire de l'empereur l'électro
également à l'honneur en ce mois de
septembre après une édition 2020 annulée
en raison de la crise sanitaire
électrique parc de château était de
retour des milliers de fêtards en
participait à cette onzième édition sur
deux jours la soirée un rhinocéros blanc
arrive au parc zoologique son nom wakati
trois ans après la mort de Vince abattue
en 2018 par des braconniers pour
récupérer sa corne enfin il nous a
quitté en ce début septembre après une
immense carrière au cinéma Jean-Paul
Belmondo alias Bebel est décédée à l'âge
de 88 ans le comédien avait passé une
partie de son enfance à Clairefontaine
en Yvelines pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale
avant de refermer ce journal attention
si vous avez prévu d'emprunter les
transports en commun ce vendredi le
mouvement de grève à la SNCF se poursuit
et va encore largement perturber le
trafic des RER et Transilien dans les
Yvelines sont concernés les RER B C E et
les lignes n etu du Transilien pour les
prévisions prévoyaient sur le RER B3
train sur 4 en heures de pointe dans la
partie sud du RER B le trafic devrait
être normal aux heures creuses sur le
RER C intrins sur 3 et pour le RER E les
lignes n etu du Transilien prévoyaient
intra sur deux la SNCF qu'on sait que
dans la mesure du possible de limiter
vos déplacements et de vérifier
l'horaire de votre train sur le site
transilien.com voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité très
belle soirée avec TV 78
[Musique]